hello and welcome to the new world of
your source for everything anime and
manga and today it's time to talk about
hunter hunter surprise surprise
specifically about one thing that just
boggles the mind when you look back on
this series and that is the whole
supposed secret of nen
and this is one of the things that kind
of drives me insane about hunter hunter
in terms of looking at the overall world
because inconsistent
is a fairly light way of putting it in
the series it is established that nen is
a dangerous art form and is thus hidden
from the world at large which works well
in theory
until it doesn't until nenesse proudly
on display in front of hundreds and
thousands of people watching a televised
fight between hunters in heaven's arena
and that's the most commonly cited
conflicting idea which we will get into
but the entire series really is just a
bit of a mess when it comes to the
alleged secrecy of men before we do
dive too heavily into that though you
can help fix this mess by subscribing to
the new world review the act of which
will fulfill the activation requirement
of my own inability which allows me the
power to make clear and concise youtube
videos no
it's not the greatest of abilities i
will admit but
that's what i've got but otherwise
getting into this topic i first want to
reaffirm the assertion that nen
is a secret in this world otherwise this
entire argument falls apart so yeah
however this notion is introduced to us
by wing in heaven's arena where he
states
nen can be destructive if abused it's
too dangerous to make it part of the
official exam
thus only people who have passed are
tested and here he is referring to the
nature of the hunter exam of course but
it speaks to the greater reality of nen
the hunter association are
apparently extraordinarily careful with
who they induct into the art form
because in the wrong hands nen can be a
terrible weapon to be used against
humanity a theme that is constantly
explored in the series all the way up to
monday with fourth prince radnick who is
undoubtedly one of the most terrifying
individuals to have ever acquired nen
at the same time i also need to point
out that the hunter association is a
massive pack of hypocrites they claim to
be careful with who they induct but at
the same time the standards for passing
the hunter exam have nothing to do with
intent or potential threat i mean for
example if hisoka was not an end user
and he passed the exam then they would
have taught him nen regardless despite
the fact that he is a major force of
chaos and death on this planet the
greater problem to do with the actual
topic though is that wing's words would
be fine if nen was restricted to hunters
then the association could
maybe effectively govern it but it isn't
the hunter association is one of many
many organizations that foster ninus and
they have zero control whatsoever over
the others
and i guess here i'd be specifically
referring to groups like the zoldic
family or the ten dons who all have
clear knowledge of men due to their
control over the shadow beast and the
abilities of neon astrad
also the mafia forces of the khakian
empire the phantom troop and
i suppose you can make the argument that
all of these groups have an incentive to
keep nenus a secret or at least keep
their own abilities a secret but my main
point here is to demonstrate that aura
manipulation is not
exclusive to hunters and it has been
disseminated into the general population
it does get a lot worse though because
let's take a look at the greed island
arc this was a game that one could only
play
via nenu's and it involved a whole host
of people who just
how are they non-users the overwhelming
majority of players we encounter on
greed island are not hunters and they
seem almost startlingly ordinary like
all of the rejects who accompany gon and
the important characters to the
dodgeball match with razer not to
mention genthro as well he's not a
hunter he isn't
actually in anything he just knows nen
and he knows it
very well and at this point i would like
to just expand on the idea of nen that
is the name given to the art form
of wielding aura one can be a conscious
or a user without referring to nen in
any way however the vast majority of
these ori users that we encounter have
this
intimate academic scale knowledge of nen
specifically which may or may not have
needed to come directly from the shingen
ryu school of kung fu because that's the
only institution we're aware of that
teaches aura manipulation specifically
as nen as in with the basic principles
advanced principles all that labeling
etc so i do find it a bit odd that every
single conscious aura user in the series
seems to have studied this one
methodology of practice
but this is all before we even get into
the idea of using nen as entertainment
for the general public heaven's arena
poses a huge
huge huge problem to this world because
this is where at its highest levels
only nen users can compete and in order
to do so they need to proudly display
their abilities in front of a live
audience as well as televised audiences
and sometimes i suppose that can work
out pretty alright because most uses of
nen would be invisible to those who do
not use aura themselves but certainly
not all of them for example almost any
use of conjuration is visible to the
human eye such as castro creating an
entire aura clone of himself against
hisoka and speaking of hisoka he also
quite
casually stated key details regarding
nine in his fight against gon and even
went on to explain his own
ability just you know in front of the
whole world
so the idea of nen being a secret to the
world under these circumstances
to me it's a bit of a joke but let's
look at the very best case scenario we
can and that would be that the world of
hunter hunter is one of established
quote-unquote
magic question mark things like magical
beasts do exist and they are common
knowledge so do various superhuman
abilities some of which have never been
explained by men for example killer's
ability to grow claws out of nowhere i
mean maybe it could be an unconscious
use of enhancement but sure that's fine
i'm willing to accept that killer just
has a superhuman ability there but then
you have a scenario where
thousands and thousands of people flock
to see a battle between superhumans
using primarily but not always
invisible powers and are you trying to
tell me that not one of these people is
curious to know how they are able to
perform these feats
that is the very best case scenario just
a general acceptance that there are
superhumans in the world but even then
with that knowledge wouldn't you
you know maybe i don't know want to
study them
figure out how these powers emerge
whether or not you could isolate certain
genes or practices that led to them
no no one no like government agency or
extraordinarily wealthy kingdom no one's
interested in superpowers and how they
could benefit them in fact as an example
of that we can take a look at the
khaking empire this is one of the
wealthiest nations on the planet capable
of comfortably coughing up the cash for
an expedition to the dark continent
their royal family is beyond wealthy and
also very much beyond the law they have
access to anything they so desire and
yet almost none of them have any
knowledge of net you know that thing
that they can watch on tv at any given
time and also that thing that is known
by a lot of their underlings as well by
the way it always strikes me as a bit
strange to think that fourth prince
ryannick's entire mafia family and end
users and he had no idea it even existed
until now and i don't know i think i
just find it pretty hard to believe that
you can keep that knowledge of nen from
the richest and most well-connected
people on the planet yet miscellaneous
non-hunter greed island rejects can be
well aware of it and once again it is
inconsistent because select members of
the karkin empire are nen users such as
benjamin and camilla and then the
question pops up well how did they
stumble into it to the point where they
are extraordinarily proficient users
and the other princes didn't in reality
what should have occurred is exactly
what happened with the chimera ants
upon their first exposure of nine they
discovered that it was a very useful
phenomenon and did everything they could
to learn about it swiftly and put it to
use in order to propagate their colony
that is how things should be
everywhere in hunter hunter some
incredibly rich piece of royalty or a
businessman entrepreneur becomes curious
about all of the super powers being
blatantly displayed in heaven's arena
and then they invest shocking amounts of
resources into learning and commodifying
it
at which point maybe a natural
counter-argument would be well the
hunter association might step in to shut
that down
but in many cases these kingdoms are
significantly more powerful and more
influential than the hunter association
and even if the hunter association did
have that power it still would not be
possible to do in all cases because nen
is just known by
so so many people all a really wealthy
person would have to do is offer a
random greed island player a ton of
money and then all of a sudden they have
a working theoretical knowledge of aura
control there are just too many
miscellaneous people in the world of
hunter hunter to keep them more quiet
and surprisingly few are bound by the
mission and morals of the hunter
association the hunter association
aren't some sort of global
nen police but even those without the
resources would be very eagerly
reporting on and following these
superhuman figures very very closely
just like in every superhero movie as
soon as society discovers someone with
an amazing ability then they are an
instant celebrity and with heaven's
arena in mind someone like hisoka should
have
thousands and thousands of fans that
maybe even stalk him everywhere he goes
because he is a celebrity and i could
say the same about crollo as well given
that he's a floor master and the only
way you could really avoid that effect
is to have a world like my hero academia
where quirks are so painfully common
that no one really cares anymore but
togashi seems to be trying to play it
both ways with hunter hunter
having super secret powers that can be
used in super public ways and resulting
in the general public having this
inexplicable disinterest in all of these
rare funky powers
it makes no sense to me and the only
real explanation i have comes from the
meta narrative viewpoint
nen is a secret unless it's not it
depends entirely on whatever idea
togashi wants to explore at any given
time if we require an arc like the
hunter exam or the chimera ants when nen
is a secret to be discovered then it is
perfectly hidden from the world in every
way however if an arc requires that we
demonstrate nen combat in front of
hundreds perhaps thousands of people
like kevin's arena or even the
succession war well then everyone knows
about nen
unless they don't somehow but lots of
them
do and if they don't they should be
curious to find out but that's just
hunter hunter and i should say that
while i was researching this video i
came across a very interesting question
by a reddit user named
manic marshall in regards to nen and the
idea he poses is that because aura is a
latent power residing in all living
things
is it morally acceptable to keep that
knowledge from people and we know that
the general theory is that it must be
kept under wraps out of fear of misuse
but there is a lot of good that can be
done with nen as well the most basic
benefits would be the extension of life
learning how to control one's aura can
add significant amounts to an
individual's lifespan but it even goes
on to greater ideas such as furthering
human evolution in general and this was
something else that the chimera ants
nailed very quickly after they
discovered then the decision was made to
awaken their entire
colony because it was seen as far more
beneficial for their race to have access
to their innate powers rather than deny
that and as such the chimera ants
evolved quite rapidly into an
apocalyptic level threat which shows
both the strengths and dangers of men
meanwhile humanity is almost
deliberately stunting its growth by
gatekeeping ore control and it is a
tricky thing because we're talking about
the right of someone to understand and
use their own life energy
it's not an optional power you know it's
not a situation where we're asking
ourselves well
should we inject everyone with a genetic
serum to turn them into super soldiers
or something along those lines
because in the case of hunter hunter
everyone in this world is already an
aura user to some degree
so i don't know ask yourselves right
here and now if you had a latent ability
to control a greater degree of your own
life and it was being kept from you by
some unknown authority how would you
feel about it it's a tricky question and
it probably has a greater good answer
attached to it
i do find it interesting though because
some of isaac netaro's final words in
this world were don't underestimate
humanity's potential for evolution and
at the same time at the helm of humanity
he was deliberately limiting its
evolution
although to be fair in the manga that
word also could have been read as malice
but the anime chose evolution but that
tangent aside nen secrecy makes little
to no sense
in hunter hunter in terms of story
relevance it's supposed to be a hidden
art form only wielded by those of a
secret society or secret societies
plural despite that nen is undeniably
present in very prominent aspects of
daily life including entertainment
and really when it comes down to it
there is very little logic to who is and
who is not allowed to be a nen user it
just boils down to whoever togashi needs
to be one
it does make sense that characters like
gone are unaware of nen he grew up on an
isolated island same with grapica he
grew up in an isolated village clan
however for everyone who lives in big
cities and more active parts of
civilization
it's very difficult for me to buy that
they are not aware of men
in at least the vaguest of senses of the
existence of superhuman abilities
and from there for there to not be any
sense of curiosity and entrepreneurship
associated is quite unthinkable and a
pretty big disconnect luckily i suppose
honda hunter spends most of its arcs in
more isolated scenarios and it is easy
to forget about but the secrecy of nine
is one of those things that just slipped
through the cracks with togashi but what
do you guys think please do leave your
thoughts in the comments below or even
join my discord server and if you're
keen for some more hunt onto content
then please to go and check out some of
my other videos or even subscribe to the
channel for regular hunter hunter glory
delivered straight into
your youtube feed but for now this has
been the new world review and i'll see
you next time